le sud de la france est une nouvelle
fois frappé par de violentes intempéries
le pire est à venir selon les
prévisionnistes il est déjà tombé deux
mois de pluie en quelques heures et se
sont transformées en torrents ce week
end 22 départements ont été placés en
vigilance orange les bouches du rhône le
var et les alpes-maritimes sont en
vigilance rouge quant à eux de fortes
précipitations qui ont obligé les
autorités à faire fermer les écoles et
les universités dans ces régions nous
ont rappelé j'ai reçu un appel conquois
fallait venir chea cheat ce que l'école
allait fermer radar préfecture alors
qu'il est tombé près de trois mois de
pluie en 24 heures les habitants sont
priés de rester chez eux tant que la
tempête sévit à abandonner car un jeu
j'ai vu que ça craignait au niveau
d'électricité j'ai eu par une accalmie
de voit se profiler au courant de la
nuit
on espère dans le courant de la nuit
peut être qu'une accalmie va normalement
intervenir alors on vous a fait une
compile de regarder ce qui se passe
notamment à marseille on pense très fort
à tous les marseillais qui sont dans le
désarroi regarder les images sont
vraiment impressionnantes
[Musique]
ans
nous
[Musique]
c'est les images impressionnantes et
voiture c'est ton bâtiment ouais c'est
mon bâtiment est fière de ma voiture
normalement la voie juste là en bas
c'est incroyable a jusque là le bâtiment
jeudi j'avais de l'eau 1,88 j'avais de
l'eau jusqu'aux genoux non ce qui ce qui
s'est passé raconte moi comment tu as
découvert ça qui est bien commun je suis
rentré fait je suis rentré hier soir il
commence à pleuvoir et tout ça et je
suis premier jour de vacances jeu pour
moi je pensais faire une grasse mat et
mon père il est rentré vraiment il est
rentré il me dit une fête en voiture le
prend l'eau je commande en voiture mais
tu vois elle est montée moi je sors en
claquettes je vois le truc de l'eau
jusqu'aux genoux je suis mais ici c'est
quoi ce truc j'ai jamais vu ça jamais vu
ça et ma voiture vraiment avec eux en
fait ça lui donne là je sais pas si vous
voyez sur l'image en fait je venais
juste à côté en fait
avec lui vaut un accroc l'état les
intempéries qui a eu parce qu'il ya peu
le des gorges de fait en fait depuis un
moment dessus l'ol est monté à les
monter à les monter et ma voiture même
avec le frein à main allait monter
jouant avec le frein à main était
soulevée à la et et périph elle est
partie à droite à gauche il a tapé
contre les murs et voilà c'est jamais vu
le camion blanc là vous voyez sur
l'image m en clair il a vu en direct il
a voulu faire
ce qu'il fallait pas il arrivait à
pleine balle et l'ol est passé au dessus
et là un peu plus bas normands une
boulangerie la boulangerie c'est pareil
la boulangerie elle est complètement 1re
as fait il y avait le cas d'une vidange
de vidange âge qui étaient là toute la
journée ils ont essayé de vie dvi dvi d
et là le problème qui se passe c'est que
avec les poubelles qui ont pas été
ramassées depuis vendredi parce que
vendredi moi je dis j'ai des amis en moi
qui sont dans les beaux quartiers
chez eux ça a été ramassé de suite non
votre chien oui mais par contre nous on
sa masse des tas d'ordures depuis des
jours et des jours et des jours des rats
qui nous sortent comme pas possible non
et là le truc je vous dis sur des
voitures les voitures des sacs poubelles
monter dessus des couches des serviettes
hygiéniques des choses comme ça et on le
vit sur ça on vit sur sa dejala je vous
dis ce matin des rats qui me passait
entre les jambes qu'est ce que vous
voulez faire je voulais faire c'est
cesser c'est incroyable ce que nous
décrit content vous avez pas vu arriver
le lot ccs arrivé soudainement mais
c'est vraiment il a commencé à pleuvoir
vous dis franchement sur le coup de
minuit mais avait de la pluie on se dit
je sors du bâtiment il pleut c'est
habituel c'est une grosse pluie il avait
annoncé dès fin des averses mais
c'est marseille nous y pas ce qu'on ne
dit pas le genre c'est oui ça tombe fort
et après ça se passe là vraiment c'est
sûr levé ce matin voir la voiture comme
ça voir des gens c'est aider les
personnes âgées allez allez les faire
traverser aller chercher le pen passe
comme ça
et on peut pas ne pas circuler qui se
passe sinon tu es aujourd'hui là en fait
c'est simple ils ont ouvert après ils
ont ouvert les yeux les trucs beaucoup
trop tard vous beaucoup trop vite je
sais pas mais pour circuler c'est une
catastrophe moi je vous dis dans ma rue
j'ai pas vu un bon pied j'ai pas vu un
policier j'ai vu personne personne même
pas quelqu'un de la municipalité et on a
passé la journée au téléphone des gens
que je croisais qui étaient là dans ma
rue qui étaient là qui appelait qui
disait bonjour est ce que c'est possible
oui oui c'est moi ça arrive avant 11h30
machin va venir on va venir on attend
toujours ce que tu le dis c'est que dans
les quartiers plus huppés mais je vous
dis rue paradis je vous prépare à dire
marseille je pense qu'elle est très
connue rue paradis et vendredi soir il y
avait plus rien ces autres explique sa
gym parce que ça c'est inadmissible ce
que nous dit content en fait oui il ya
des problèmes sociaux liés au ramassage
d'ordures à marseille est là clairement
ils ont ciblé leurs quartiers c'est à
dire que ils ont voulu aller dans les
quartiers les plus accessibles ne
pourrait plus près là où sacyr que le
mieux est franchement vous décrire une
situation qui est réel et qui est
totalement injuste mais pour les
quartiers populaires notamment les
quartiers est de marseille ont été
totalement abandonnée par les services
d'urbanisme il faut le dire depuis
plusieurs jours je sais pas non plus
surtout c'est pas ça c'est qu'ils sont
d'une grève qui sort d'une grève et
savent qu'il ya des ordures mais quand
je vous dis des ordures c'est dément
c'est un gamin là je sais pas faire le
marseillais c'est vraiment des montagnes
d'ordures des montagnes d'ordures je
peux parfois leur dire on vous paye les
heures supplémentaires venir travailler
jour et nuit vous travaillez vous
ramasser tous concernent en fait de la
mairie bas mot sur deux jours bien sûr
c'est que les trucs n'est pas coté et
n'ont pas été touchés depuis des années
des années jeudi les démons d'ordures
dès qu'il pleut un peu à marseille ça
monte de suite et
je te sens je te sens très triste que tu
vois ah oui et était pas aussi sûrement
parce qu'ils voient tout ce qu'ils ont
construit même série que d'acheter une
voiture c'est un qui tu la vois partir
tu vois tu vois ton tu dois tout tout
tout tout ton quartier partir un de ses
locaux comment ça c'est que je vois tous
vraiment toutes les voitures vraiment
toutes les voitures là toute la journée
voyez les voitures qui sont centralisés
toute la journée c'était dépendance sur
des poneys sur des panneaux et les
camions les 6 et la sai on a essayé de
pousser de les retirer tout est
l'ambiance dans la ville le moral y
voyez là dans le quartier franchement
c'est tout on essaie d'être solidaire on
essaye de cd avec les joues dix mois que
je suis comme ça et qu'on aurait vu des
personnes âgées les personnes
handicapées qui essayait de traverser je
les aide parce que je vous dis c'est pas
tout puisque marseille c'est ça le
problème il est là c'est qu'avec l'eau
qui a eu en plus c'est qu'on n'a de la
boue par terre et avec la boue le truc
des personnes âgées ciel à l'église mais
même moi même moi j'ai feuilleté j'ai
failli tomber tout à l'heure en travers
ça j'ai une personne âgée halton elle
s'éclate au sol elle s'éclate au sol se
fait moins donc là là aujourd'hui vous
êtes laide paralysé la ville est
paralysée enfin le quartier là il parle
à nous il après je vous dis j'ai regardé
j'ai des amis à moi qui sont un peu plus
haut sur la valentine séparé de la
valentine vraiment c'est en fait le
quartier c'est selon les endroits où
c'est vraiment le fossé mais
malheureusement vu que les travaux n'ont
pas été faits c'est tout tu des cubes
d'eau et là je sais que sa reprise sur
le 11e tout à l'heure on en voit en
envoyant une enquête ou en magie mais
devant chez lui toute fin de match mon
collègue c'est s était plein d'eau
c'était le retour plein au jeu il m'a
dit me dis ce soir comment alors comment
vous faites là vous pouvez rentrer chez
vous ou pas du tout je peux rentrer à
pied centre appelé mais j'ai de l'eau
jusqu'aux genoux aujourd'hui j'étais
déjà été ramenés des chaussures ont été
envoyées par des rats qui vous passe les
aurions pas retourner les ordures de
partout je vous dis les ordures le floch
elle flotte serviette hygiénique qui te
passe entre les jambes c'est alors j'ai
rien contre ça mais
c'est pas fait passer pour elle car
voilà non mais c'est comment tu tes
parents et on dit quoi il un parent à
moi mon père je vous dis seul truc qu il
est passé il m'arrivait avant la vie mon
père est l'agent de sécurité pourquoi
pas d'accord et toi tu es tu fais coup
tu fais quoi toi moi je suis je suis
responsable dans un magasin de sport n'a
pas l'air très clair tout ça
[Rires]
l'histoire de l'île d'accord j'ai bien
fait beaucoup de choses chez sport 2000
c'est vrai je ne te cache pas
ça va et donc là le magasin ouvertes
c'est bon c'est tu peux le magasin alors
moi je te dis c'est mon premier jour de
vacances à la base aujourd'hui c'est
vrai et je perde en avant ma voiture
premier jour de vacances rires je sais
pas pourquoi j'ai eu un pressentiment a
commencé à pleuvoir et je ne sais pas je
la bouger puisque gonfle mj avec la
foire de marseille et où il n'ya pas de
place devant chez moi je dis tant pis
j'ai trouvé une place j'y reste
je vois tu vas bouger c'est incroyable
ce qu'on voit là un c pour l'orge
iranien mana le ministre de l'intérieur
est allé jusqu'à demander aux gens de ne
pas sortir de chez eux regardent 101 un
message d'avertissement pour les
populations de ne pas sortir de chez
elles de ne pas se mettre près des cours
d'eau par près de la mer et de faire
attention aux installations électriques
et de faire évidemment attention au plus
proche de soi beaucoup de moyens des
pompiers sont mobilisés les préfets sont
mobilisés bien évidemment mais chacun
par son comportement doit faire
attention aux personnes les plus
fragiles ne pas sortir de chez soi je le
répète
alors pas sortir de chez soi aussi je
vous dis on voit la jsms la voix la
série qu il ya la prolifération des rats
spyro's
et c'est vrai que ces enfants là
normalement il faut vraiment les gars
urgence vraiment pas à régler ce
problème parce que vous pouvez pas
rester comme ça oui valérie mais
justement qu'est ce qu'on vous dit est
ce que vous avez eu accès aux aubes
services de la mairie aux pompiers est
ce que vous les avez vu est ce que vous
avez plus de dialogue avait pas vu
depuis cet arrêt du bon les
orphelinats traoré chargé non plus céder
je suis d'accord qu'il y ait des
personnes il ya des quartiers qui soit
peut-être un peu plus touchés que
d'autres mais non à côté de gijon on est
en zone inondable j'ai passé les zones
inondables en priorité c'est pas d'aller
dans les beaux quartiers d'aller faire
c'est d'aller faire là d'un moment donné
nous on est en galère vous voyez qu'on
dise avant plus qu on a de l'eau il ya
l'huveaune qui est juste à côté l'ol va
forcément monter de la station
d'épuration à la 600 m c'est un point
stratégique un point stratégique les
personnes doivent venir dans ces
endroits là qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
dans les beaux quartiers c'est à dire
qu'ils ont
ramassé des parmi les poubelles ils ont
fait venir des gens pour aider les
périodes tutelle ont ramassé les
poubelles sont passés avec son visuel à
mulhouse au lycée c'est la lucidité qui
est venu avons ramassé les poubelles
c'est notre société non ils ont là aussi
les gros camions blain métropoles
marseille c'est les mêmes qui ramasse
les poubelles avec les trucs
vendredi soir j'étais chez mon collègue
de rue par hadji au premier étage du
dessus ils ont ramassé les poubelles
c'est quoi la situation là donc là ça
cette minorité il devrait avoir une il
devrait avoir une accalmie franchement
j'espère j'espère pour que pour qu'on
puisse avancer qu'on puisse réparer un
peu les dégâts après je dis là pour le
moment on essaie de faire au mieux j'ai
vu des trucs sur dans le onze c'est
beaucoup le 11e les quartiers on fait
vraiment le quartier est qu'ils ont pris
beaucoup beaucoup jeu des routes vu que
c'est des petites des petites rues
étroites se sont effondrés complètement
des voitures tombées l'une sur l'autre
j'ai vu ça c'est jeu la voiture allait
ou là à la gelée pousser et se pousser
de l'eau gelée mini un peu plus loin
c'est tout je t'attends béja temps et
renault ils ont fermé du coup donc pour
le moment c'est mort la voiture se
palper d'un pas sur
la première fois ces niches est de plus
en plus tant la dernière fois qu'on
entre en mars est que les poubelles sont
pas ramassées faut vraiment se pencher
sur cette société privée qui ramasse les
poubelles à marseille voire changer les
contrats dames et prendre une autre
société ce qui s'étaient mis en grève
c'est marseille c'est ludivine hoguet
problème de décharge quentin dire
aujourd'hui ce avec quoi la fuite alors
qu'est ce que tu attends là donc l'atlas
huit mois déjà qu'ils viennent nettoyer
un peu leur bronzage tout cela vraiment
je vous dis on marche dans la boue
vraiment il faut une
jolie terrasse et un vrai problème c'est
incroyable que la mairie n'ait pas
réalisé pas de nouvelles à la c1 c'est
ce que là je peux vous dire ça ces
vecteurs de maladie extrêmement grave
pour les enfants pour les personnes plus
âgées c'est ça voilà est donc là
aujourd'hui il faut il faut vite qu'à
faire quelque chose qu'il ya une
situation d'urgence et aujourd'hui
pouvez pas ne pouvait pas vu comme ça le
loup elle et jusqu'aux genoux vous
rendez compte ou pas et donc c'est un
truc de fou font apparaître ses terres
au dessin de jeu quand je suis parti de
loin elle était redescendue elle était
redescendue correctement parce qu'ils
ont ouvert fin je sais même pas ce
qu'ils ont fait un peu plus loin
franchement je ne me limite je m'en fous
c'est juste qu'il fasse partir l'eau qui
viennent nettoyer enfin il ya un
accident il c'est d'intervenir tout de
suite mais là le bois les gens du
quartier mais les jeunes du quartier ils
sont là il y en a il y en a qui ont des
trucs dans leur cave je vous dit le
boulanger qui est un peu plus bas lui et
sa boulangerie aller partent à ses
joueurs allaient morte l'amdi l'eau qui
était monté dans ses présentoirs ces cui
cae avait pour lui oui je pense que
c'est cuit il y avait un monsieur qui
était là j'ai parlé avec plusieurs
personnes qui étaient là dans leur
garage l'ol était monté tellement il y
en a c'est les voitures forcément qu'ils
étaient dans les garages qui sont mortes
après on a cédé souvenirs de famille des
choses comme ça je sais tu sais les gens
ils s'occupent pas non plus que des
trucs inutiles dans l'est dans les trucs
dans les garages et des cd des photos de
famille des choses comme ça etc des
souvenirs et souvenirs tu portes et se
lever le matin voir des choses comme ça
c'est dur jeudi à l'école qui était là
juste en face le matin jeudi ont pendant
45 minutes j'étais là déjà en train
d'essayer de pousser la voiture les
enfants qui sortaient de l'école déjà
avec l'eau qui est là bon
tu vois qu'il ya des trucs dit d'envoyer
un message de matteo morandi de ne pas
venir je suis ce que la sachant qu'il ya
l'huveaune qui à côté il va y avoir des
rares il fonctionne pour les enfants
c'est pas ce n est pas sur le climat est
vraiment passé et il va prendre quand
même plusieurs jours on pourrait à tout
nettoyer c'est vraiment
normal ah oui et donc toi ton vacances
ou moins de temps à 15 jours 15 jours
donc que tu vas faire tes quoi
des pieds à la salle de sport spa ce que
j'ai à faire
mme haïder foot foot mais bon c'est un
peu loin de croire qu'un collectif de
m'emmener c'est tout écoutez si je peux
t'aider en tout cas si tu veux c'est
plus et de l'eau car vraiment aidé et
des
dons pour le quartier vraiment où je te
le dis pour pour essayer de faire
avancer plus vite les choses parce que
voir de quoi ils ont besoin on va se
renseigner dès demain matin et on va
essayer de faire un don pour le quartier
pour que ça aille plus vite et pour que
vraiment aux poussières et reprendre une
vie normale assez rapidement donc on va
s'en occuper dès demain réd aidez nous
mon quentin et vraiment je te dis on est
avec toi fonds et merci d'avoir témoigné
validé le café et je sais que les
prochaines vacances je t'enverrai
j'aurai bientôt envoyer en vacances
voilà ça me frappe ça me fera plaisir
par cible voilà très bien voilà je te le
dis un grand plaisir merci en tout cas
content